All right, let's go. Welcome back to
another video. I'm going to be showing
you the trade that secured me over 125
points on the Nasdaq and 2.5 R inside
the lunch macro. So, let's get straight
into it. Firstly, we can see price has
come back down into a discount and has
swept London lows. As we're inside of
the lunch macro, we actually only have
around 4 minutes till we can see a
setup. So, the fact that we've swept
London lows, and you can see right here
that price is putting a short-term high
on NQ. We have one on ES. And
simultaneously, we put in a bearish
order block. So, we'd want to see a
market structure shift
through this swing high and inversing
that bearish order block at the same
time. So, let's see if we have that
happen.
All right, there we go. Perfect. So,
exactly what we need to see on the 11th
and 12th minute before the end of this
macro, a shift in market structure on
both NQ and ES. This is perfect. If it
were to hold up a gap now, this would be
a setup. All right, so there we go. So,
NQ has put in a fair value gap, so has
the ES. So, this is a valid long. And
what we also need to check is the bias.
So, on the 4-hour time frame, we're
trading out of this 4-hour bullish gap.
If we look on the 1-hour,
we're trading out of this 1-hour bullish
gap. Look on the 15, we're trading out
of that 15. If we look at the five as
well, trading out of a 5-minute bullish
gap, too. So, we have a completely fully
bullish bias. What we got so far, sweep
of London lows, shift in market
structure on both NQ and ES, fair value
gap both, paired with this mitigation
block because the previous short-term
low was not swept. So, therefore, it is
a mitigation. Okay, so just a tap of
this fair value gap, and we'll be in for
longs. And there we go. That's a long
right there. And I'm running my stop to
this short-term low for 53 points. And
then, I'm running it to the draw on buy
side liquidity
for 122 points. I actually got a better
fill. My fill was around
down this point here. So, it was around
2.
45 R and 125 points. That was where I
got filled on when I actually took the
live trade. You guys will be seeing that
all over YouTube and Instagram. As we're
going through this position, you want to
look how you're going to trail your stop
loss as price is moving into a profit.
So, let's see how price reacts.
Okay, so what we can see here is price
has come down. We're in a little bit of
drawdown
and it's tapped into this bullish order
block. So, this is why I wanted to put
my stop loss at this short-term low
because it's also protected by this
bullish order block and there's a very
low chance price will come down and take
sell stops again. Especially, this is
basically a point of minor sell side. If
you look on the 5-minute time frame,
it's actually a 5-minute swing low once
that candle actually closes. So, that
would be
not a point I'd say price would draw to,
especially with how much price has been
dumping from the New York session. What
I'd want to see is price react off this
bullish order block.
And if price was to take this first
short-term high,
that is where that would be where I'd
look to trail my stop loss. So, there we
go. Price wicks out of that bullish
order block perfectly. And then, it
reacts nicely into a profit, taking out
that first short-term high. So, it'll be
trailing stops
to this short-term low,
reducing risk slightly from 51 points
to 37. So, now we're looking at
potentially how to go risk-free on this
trade.
Where we would go risk-free on this
trade, we can see this short-term high
is 50% of the range between our entry
point and TP.
That's where I would look to go break
even.
Perfectly takes that midway point. So,
that's where I'd now go break even,
risk-free on this trade.
Okay, so now what we can see is price is
moving nicely into a profit. However,
there's nowhere to really trail my stop
loss to yet. I don't see any valid
points to do that, and I want to let my
trade run. We're only up around 1 R on
this position, so I want to see it run
all the way.
We have this bullish order block that
price could potentially respect.
And
push off high. Okay, so what we can see
here is price is still respecting this
bullish order block. I'm still not going
to trail my stop loss. I want to see
price at least take out this short-term
high.
Okay, and you can still see here we are
still respecting this bullish order
block to the left.
All right, there we go. So, now it's
actually been inversed. But what you'll
now see here is if we go into the
5-minute time frame, price is actually
trading out of a 5-minute bullish gap.
And that's going to be overlapping with
all of our bullish confluences to the
left, those bullish imbalances. So, this
is why I did not want to trade I did not
want to trail my stop loss because there
was a very high chance that price would
come down, take out these points of sell
stops, tap into this 5-minute bullish
gap, and then it's going to send it
higher. So again, price has come down,
taken sell stops yet again.
My stop loss is in a very nice position.
I'm going to tell you why because
my entry at the time was around this
point here. Yeah, it was a little bit
lower. We're below this breakaway gap.
So, we actually got a model inside of
the model. We got shift in market
structure. Price left behind a fair
value gap as it displaced. So, that's a
breakaway gap.
It's very low probable that price
actually returns to a breakaway gap. In
this scenario here with our trade as
well, we got a tap off that point. But
for a second time, it's very unlikely,
you know? Price eventually has to go
make that run on sell stops. Like,
there's no way it comes back. Yeah,
there's no way. So, you just got to use
your initiative and just know this is
the likely scenario. And that's what I
stuck with. This is what I was waiting
for. I still, you know, okay, you can
basically trail your stop loss here. But
at this point, you know,
I still wouldn't be surprised if price
comes down,
taps into some of these confluences. We
got a bullish order block here. We've
got these short-term lows here. If it
taps into it again and then goes higher
because we're in this we're currently in
this period between the lunch macro and
the PM macro where it consolidates a
little bit and then it finally makes its
move. So, where price is now drawing
higher,
All right, this is why I'm so confident
price is going to hit that point on buy
side. As someone who trades the PM macro
every single day, what you usually see
happen is that the New York session will
be quite dry. And then, if you get a
move in the lunch macro,
it'll have its move and it'll form it'll
want to form those lunch highs and lows,
yeah? And when it forms those lunch
highs and lows, it needs to go and take
out those points on buy side or sell
side. Now, the fact that the whole of
the New York session, the AM session,
we've been taking out points of sell
side, and now I was expecting it to
retrace and take out points on buy side.
And then for the PM session, it will
continue lower, which I actually believe
the PM did then sell off after taking
those points on buy side. And then we
saw it continued higher onto today where
price is trading at all-time highs. So,
that's basically why I was expecting it
to go take out this point on buy side
and then come down lower for the PM
session.
So,
I'm still not even going to bother
trailing my stop. At this point, I was
expecting price, you know, it's not even
a matter of if it hits TP, it's a matter
of when.
And then we can see we have uh
this crazy
We have that crazy Trump candle which uh
very nearly takes TP in around, you
know, from 40 points all the way
to 90 points, 50 points in that one
candle. That's crazy. And then the
second candle,
bang,
full TP hit. I mean, that is an absolute
beautiful trade right there. That's as
algorithmic as the silver bullet gets,
you know? Um when you're going for big
moves like that, especially, you know,
125 points is a pretty dirty amount. Uh
you got to be patient with these trades.
And trailing with the normal way that I
usually trail
is, you know, it's going to get stopped
out. You got to let price do its thing.
Got to let it move. And that comes from
understanding what price action does and
how it actually, you know, presents
itself between the macros. That's why I
really enjoy the macros because I can
understand what happens in between and
what the different scenarios will be.
So, yeah.
Uh for today, I didn't even bother going
live cuz we were trading at all-time
highs all day. And the times it did
retrace, there wasn't really anything
much to take anyway. Uh
I did come back, however, from the gym
because like I said, uh we had a bit of
a retracement. As we were trading at
all-time highs, I was expecting price to
retrace again, sweep out some points of
sell side, and then push up higher again
to all-time highs. And I wanted to catch
the move back up towards all-time highs,
but it already did it before the PM
macro. So, I basically came back to a
pretty dead session. I mean, it's
literally just Yeah, it's it's it's just
at all-time highs again. So, not much we
can really do about that. Yo, Nasdaq's
nearly at 30,000 as well. That's crazy.
I hope you guys have enjoyed this video.
If you did find it helpful, then drop a
like.
Subscribe if you want to see more stuff.
Drop a comment down below
what other videos you want to see. We've
got some more videos coming, you know,
every single week, guys. This is a very
very underrated channel in my opinion,
you know? Um
I'm dropping vlogs, breakdowns, live
trades,
you know, everything you guys basically
want to see. If you want to see when I
take these trades in real time, it's all
in the description below. All you need
to do is join the free Discord, or
there's also a link that takes you to
the website, and you can join directly
from there. And if you need some
evaluations, you need a discount on them
from Alpha Futures, use code Ash10.
You'll get a discount from there.
Currently, it is, I believe, 25% off
with these new premium plans, but that's
only till May 8th. So, get on those
ASAP.
So, I hope you guys have enjoyed, and
I'll catch you in the next one. Peace.